If you've ever worked in a help desk,
then you're probably very familiar with
remote desktop connections. This is when
you can share someone else's desktop
while sitting at your desk. That user's
desktop may be in the next room, the
next building over, or the next country.
You're able to make this connection
using a number of different utilities.
You might be using RDP, which is part of
the Microsoft Remote Desktop Protocol.
There are clients or applications you
can run to connect to other RDP services
in Mac OS, Linux, Windows, your mobile
devices, and almost any other operating
system. There's of course open- source
options available for remote desktop
using VNC. This is the virtual network
computing. It uses a protocol known as
RFB or remote frame buffer. There are
also clients available on many different
operating systems. If you're using VNC
for your remote desktop connection,
remote desktop enables any organization
to support everyone in the field
regardless of where they might be, but
scammers love to use remote desktop as
well. So, if you find that a third party
is trying to connect to you using remote
desktop, you might want to get a bit
more information before allowing a third
party access to your computer.
One way to tell if someone has a remote
desktop service running on their system
is to check available open ports. The
remote desktop service, of course, is
waiting for someone to connect to that
device to be able to control it. If
someone has an open port of TCP port
3389,
then they are most likely running a
remote desktop service and someone with
the correct credentials would be able to
connect to this device and be able to
control the desktop. Of course, someone
might be running VNC or one of the many
other third-party remote desktop
solutions out there. They're usually
just secured with a username and a
password. This makes it very easy to
perform a brute force attack. So, you
might want to add additional
authentication factors to keep anyone
from connecting to your device from a
remote location. Attackers love to take
advantage of open ports for remote
desktop and easy to find usernames and
passwords because once they're on a
system, it's all theirs as if they were
sitting in front of the computer
physically. They're able to go through
all of your files. They're able to
connect to other sites and they're able
to perform whatever they'd like to do
from your machine using remote desktop.
If you have a mobile device or a laptop
and you need to connect back to your
corporate office across the internet,
then you're probably very familiar with
a VPN. This is a virtual private network
and it encrypts all of the data going
back and forth between you and the other
device, even if you're going across a
public network like the internet. From
your device, you're connecting to a VPN
concentrator. This is a centralized
device. Usually, it's at your point of
business and everyone who needs access
to your company is going to use the VPN
client on their computer to connect to
the VPN concentrator at your corporate
office. You may find that you have a
single appliance or server that's
configured as a VPN concentrator, but
these days you often find VPN
concentrators built into next generation
firewalls. This gives you options as to
how you'd like to deploy these VPN
services. You can build your own
softwarebased VPN or you can use an
integrated hardwarebased VPN that may be
part of your nextG firewall. Some VPN
concentrators require that you install
special software on your client machine.
Other operating systems have builtin
VPNs and you may be able to connect to
the VPN concentrator using software
that's already available in Windows,
Linux, or Mac OS.
Here's how a VPN works visually. You're
the remote user at home that needs to
access resources that are on your
corporate network, but your only
connection is through the internet, and
you certainly don't want to send
unencrypted information across that
public network. So, you'll use VPN
software on your remote device to
encrypt all of the data sent across the
internet. And on the other side, the
device that is acting as your VPN
concentrator will decrypt that
information and send it into your
corporate network. For this information
to get back to you, we simply reverse
this process. So information is sent
from your corporate network. It hits the
VPN concentrator where it is encrypted,
sent across the internet, and it's
decrypted on your local device at home.
We rely on VPNs to encrypt and secure
all of the data that we're sending
across the network. This means that if
someone's taking a packet capture or has
some way to view the information that
we're sending across the network would
not be able to see any of the data since
it's all encrypted over the network.
When you're connecting to that
concentrator, you're often asked for
some type of authentication credentials.
If you're only using a username and
password, there is a potential that
someone could perform a brute force
attack to try to determine the best
combination to gain access to that
system. This means that we often have
additional multiffactor authentication
that we use during this login process.
So we might provide a username, a
password, and then an additional code
that's provided to us from an app. This
ensures that only people authorized are
able to gain access to this virtual
private network.
As an administrator, there may be times
when you need to connect to a remote
device and be able to make a
configuration change at the console of
that device. In order to have a
protected communication between your
device and the remote device, you would
probably use SSH or secure shell. Secure
shell is designed for terminal
communication like the one you see here,
and it uses TCP port 22 in order to
communicate. This looks and feels very
similar to the older Tnet protocol which
runs on TCP port 23, but all of the
communication used by Tnet is sent in
the clear across the network. If you
want to have an encrypted connection to
that remote device, you'll always want
to use secure shell.
There's a great deal of security built
into SSH, which is why it's a great
utility to use for connecting to that
remote terminal. Since all of the SSH
communication is sent and encrypted,
there's no way for anyone to perform a
packet capture and somehow determine
what your username and password might
be. You can enhance the use of SSH by
adding additional authentication
options. For example, SSH supports the
use of public private key pairs to add
additional authentication for connecting
to that remote device. And as a best
practice, it's probably a good idea to
disable any type of remote access to
certain usernames. For example, the root
account on a Linux machine is the super
user of that device, and you probably
don't want people being able to log in
as root by using SSH. Some organizations
have completely removed all
password-based authentication, and they
require a certificate to be able to
authenticate to these remote devices.
You can enhance this by limiting who's
able to connect to these remote devices
based on an IP address. So, you might
want to configure a filter or network
firewall to be able to only allow access
to or from certain IP address ranges.
Many organizations have outsourced the
monitoring and ongoing maintenance of
their networks by using a managed
service provider or MSP. The MSP will
often use a tool known as an RMM in
order to provide that monitoring. RMM
stands for remote monitoring and
management. And this provides a way for
the MSP to be able to monitor and manage
all of their customers from one single
console. From this single console, your
MSP can patch operating systems, log in
remotely to a device, monitor for any
security anomalies, and provide
additional inventory of your hardware
and software.
Here's an example of an RMM that I've
used. You can see on the left side that
this MSP has six different companies
that they can access. And right now
we're looking at company 5 which has
three different locations in HQ5, LA
Office 5, and New York Office 5. You can
see across those we're looking at the LA
office right now. And the LA office has
a file server, there's Karen's laptop,
there's domain controllers and a file
server. We can also see a status of how
those devices are running. And we can
get detailed information about the
monitoring and ongoing performance of
each individual device.
This remote monitoring and management
tool has access to many different
customers from one single screen. This
makes it very attractive to an attacker
because once they get access to the RMM,
they now have access to many different
companies. This is why access to this
console should be very tightly
controlled and limited to only the
authorized users. We might also want to
require multiffactor authentication to
anyone who logs into the RMM console.
and we might want to perform ongoing
auditing to make sure that we know
exactly who's connecting to our RMM
console.
As our cloud infrastructures became
larger and larger, we needed a better
way to remotely connect and manage these
virtual machines. We were able to
provide that by using Spice. This is the
simple protocol for independent
computing environments. This allows us
to view and control the remote desktop
on a virtual machine using a very
lightweight and easy to use protocol.
This provides a seamless remote control
solution across many different operating
systems running in many different
virtual machines. If you've ever used
any type of remote control software,
then running a Spice protocol
application is going to be very similar.
Spice excels by having very efficient
graphics rendering and very fast
response times. and you're able to
integrate with that remote operating
system by sharing the folder and
clipboard between your device and the
spice enabled virtual machine.
When you run a script in Windows, you
have to connect to that Windows machine,
run the script, and then be able to see
the results of that script on something
like a remote desktop or remote terminal
screen. But what if you could send that
script to a third-party Windows device,
have it run the script, and then have
all the results of that script sent back
to you without directly connecting to
that remote device. You're able to do
that by using Windows Remote Management
or WinRM.
WinRM is turned on by default on most
Windows servers. So, all the
administrator needs to do is send the
script to that Windows server.
Obviously, the administrator will need
to authenticate to that remote device
when they're sending the script to
verify that the script is trusted. The
script then runs on that remote server,
and the resulting information is all
sent back to the original screen to be
able to evaluate what occurred during
that script.
I used Winrm on my local device to run a
script on an external server. My local
device is the NACO lab server and I'm
connecting to a server that's elsewhere
on the network called Atlantis Lab PC.
I'm running a script that performs a get
wmi object of all the Win32 services.
So, this should tell me all the services
running on that remote device. When I
send this information over, it asks for
authentication. I add my username and my
password. And what I receive in return
are the results of that script that have
run on that remote server. I didn't have
to perform a remote desktop to that
device or interactively connect through
a console or terminal. I simply used
WinRM to run that script remotely.
You might also find a number of
thirdparty tools that provide a number
of different remote management
capabilities. For example, if you need
to perform screen sharing, you can use
Go to My PC, Team Viewer, or similar
third-party utility. If you want to be
able to video conference, there are many
options available on the market. Two of
the most popular are Zoom and Webex. You
might also find tools that allow you to
easily store and transfer files between
systems. If you're using Dropbox,
Box.com, or Google Drive, then you've
taken advantage of some of this file
synchronization technology. Or if you're
performing ongoing desktop management of
a system where you're monitoring and
updating those systems, you might be
using Citrix Endpoint Management or
Manage Engine Desktop Central. All of
these thirdparty utilities have
advantages and disadvantages, but the
key to all of them is making sure that
we use appropriate security,
multiffactor authentication, and limit
access to only the people who are
authorized.